the southern nevada health district is
reporting that vaccination numbers are
beginning to slow down because of this
the cashman center mega site will close
in early may
as kate houston reports the health
district now plans to refocus their
efforts
from large sites to smaller pods
the vaccination site at cashman center
will close on may 5th
some of the staff and resources here
will now go to some smaller clinics
much like the ones the health district
has hosted since january
on thursday clark county chairwoman
marilyn kirkpatrick leaders from the
southern nevada health district and
chief greg castle of the incident
management team
gave an update on vaccination sites
numbers are falling off and we're
looking at different options going
forward of how we're going to operate to
continue to vaccinate the community
chief castle says this dip in numbers is
a routine lull after the initial rush of
each eligible tier
they're now taking a more targeted
approach to vaccinate the community
once we condense these larger sites we
will saturate the areas that really need
it
that you know have been maybe not come
to got their shot didn't want to get a
shot
try to just make it a little bit easier
for him to get to it on thursday around
2000 people got their vaccine at cashman
some think downsizing will help those
who have trouble getting to larger sites
i had to get a ride here myself
so i think if they do have more ways to
get vaccines into communities i think
that's a good thing
i have to drive all this way to find out
you know whether or not it's going to be
busy or not whereas
you know the local stations you can
actually see if it's going to be busy
probably more inclined to go get
vaccinated if you if you haven't gotten
vaccinated yet
the health district plans to utilize
community centers as well as faith-based
organizations for these smaller pods
anyone getting a first dose at cashman
over the next few weeks
will have their second dose scheduled at
the convention center
kate houston 8 news now